[Musica]
bene se siamo stiamo facendo
un'escursione in montagna e il nostro
compagno di escursione si gira verso di
noi con una faccia terrorizzata
impaurita che cosa facciamo la sua
faccia impaurita ci fa provare subito
paura e quindi prima ancora di capire se
lui sta scappando perché c'è la famosa
Orsa Gaio qualcos'altro o anche solo
un'ombra Noi siamo già lì che scappiamo
questo perché la paura serve ovviamente
a sopravvivere e passa inconsciamente
direttamente dal nostro dalla nostra
volto alle nostre gambe
Questo è un processo che conoscono molto
bene i registi per soprattutto i registi
di film horror di film thriller come per
esempio altre 10 Coq se ricordate
Infatti nella famosa scena della doccia
la protagonista è che maryon Craig a
questo volto terrorizzato Ecco cosa
succede che noi guardiamo la
protagonista e proviamo istantaneamente
lo stesso terrore questo perché le
emozioni si trasmettono si contagiano
soprattutto tramite il volto ma non solo
tramite il volto e servono a che cosa
servono cosa sappiamo davvero delle
nostre emozioni come facciamo noi a
conoscerle quello che studiamo noi nel
nostro laboratorio è come Come avvengono
Come si riconoscono le emozioni sappiamo
adesso che alcune di queste emozioni
sono così fondamentali così importanti
che nasciamo con la capacità di
riconoscerle ma anche di esprimerle sono
le emozioni fondamentali come la paura
il disgusto la rabbia la felicità la
tristezza è che ci servono per
sopravvivere
dirigono le emozioni dirigono il nostro
comportamento la nostra attenzione la
nostra memoria Quindi cosa vuol dire che
noi siamo degli animali emotivi sì
non ci piace dirlo perché abbiamo sempre
ritenuto che le emozioni fossero
qualcosa di razionale di animale la
parte più brutta dell'uomo che non
riusciamo a controllare ma è proprio
così noi siamo degli animali emotivi non
siamo per niente razionali perché è
l'emozione che guida il nostro
comportamento e lo fa per farci
sopravvivere Ma questo comporta anche
che qualcuno visto che le emozioni
governano nel nostro comportamento
possono in qualche modo provare a
rubarcele perché per trarne vantaggio
Infatti fin da stecco lo scorso quelli
che sono stati definiti persuasori
occulti hanno utilizzato questo nostro
mondo emotivo per capire come venderci
maggiormente tutti i prodotti vari tipi
di prodotti questo Perché quando noi
acquistiamo non acquistiamo un prodotto
acquistiamo un'esperienza emotiva Ecco
allora che tutte le emozioni se
conosciamo le emozioni dei consumatori
possiamo vendere meglio possiamo vendere
di più
tutti i segnali soprattutto dei motivi
sono di tipo inconscio e Questi
personaggi Diciamo che lavorano
all'interno del marketing ultimamente
hanno cominciato a fare uso di tutte le
nuove metodiche delle neuroscienze le
neuroscienze sono appunto Le Scienze che
studiano in toto il cervello e che
studiano in particolare anche tutte le
caratteristiche emotive di quello che
succede quando noi ci emozioniamo e come
le emozioni finisca poi la nostra azione
quindi
il neuromarketing è stato coniato questo
nuovo termine che cosa fa non fa altro
che andare a valutare a controllare a
misurare tutte quegli indici inconsci
che definiscono il nostro mondo emotivo
Quali sono
i segnali Vitali il battito cardiaco la
direzione dello sguardo quando guardiamo
verso qualche cosa quindi io guardo
verso qualcuno di voi sto mostrando
interesse verso qualcuno di voi e qui
c'è qualcuno che lo sa che ho molto
interesse verso di lui
e sposto la mia emozione verso
quell'oggetto Ebbene se ci sono altre
persone di fianco a me tante persone
saranno tutte portate a guardare verso
lo stesso punto Perché Perché
l'emozione perché lo sguardo dirige
l'attenzione e dirige l'emozione e
guarda caso se dopo dovremo scegliere
fra diversi oggetti che sono stati
guardati più o meno a lungo Sceglieremo
tutti l'oggetto che state guardando più
a lungo perché perché come diceva Coelho
attraverso gli occhi la nostra anima
parlano le nostre emozioni Ecco che il
neuromarketing quindi coglie tutti
questi canali questi segnali
inconsapevoli per utilizzarli per darli
al marketing per venderci dei prodotti
abbiamo detto il battito cardiaco un
altro Segnale importante è la capacità
della nostra pelle di essere
trasportata trasportare energia
elettrica o ancora ci sono dei segnali
molto diciamo
più
intellegibile più direttamente coinvolti
nel nostro mondo emotivo che sono quelli
cerebrali il neuroimaging in particolare
ci fa vedere in vivo quello che succede
quando noi abbiamo una forte emozione
quindi può essere usato per definire
quale spot meglio di un altro come
scegliamo un certo prodotto il
neuroimaging particolare la risonanza
magnetica funzionale che la metodica che
utilizziamo anche noi per ricerca ci
mostra nel cervello quale zona lavora di
più durante quel compito o Durante
l'acquisto durante la scelta di un
prodotto per esempio è stato dimostrato
che la risonanza magnetica funzionale
che quando noi dobbiamo comprare un vino
Non compriamo il vino in assoluto che
pensiamo essere il migliore ma compriamo
il vino che costa di più
persone messe dentro la risonanza
magnetica gli hanno fatto vedere tante
immagini di vini con il prezzo sotto
quale vino hanno scelto alla fine quello
che costava di più sapete perché perché
c'è una porzione della nostra corteccia
cerebrale si chiama corteccia orbita
Frontale perché sta sopra le nostre
orbite che definisce come noi facciamo
le scelte anche quelle economiche quindi
sulla base delle nostre esperienze
passate ci dice Oh Guarda che
quell'oggetto lì costa di più perché
vale di più compra quello Ecco questo è
vero Nella maggior parte dei volti ma a
volte non è vero sicuramente però il
prezzo più un oggetto è più alto prezzo
e più noi lo Sceglieremo un'altra cosa
che sappiamo sempre grazie alla
risonanza magnetica funzionale come noi
scegliamo ci fidelizziamo un Brand anche
in questo caso persone dentro la
risonanza magnetica vedevano o il loro
profumo preferito loro partner o i loro
figli e la cosa incredibile che hanno
scoperto è che l'amore per il Brand
preferito è simile all'amore coniugale
quindi è vero Quindi cosa vuol dire che
io scelgo il mio profumo
un po' come scelgo mio marito un po'
come la mamma mio marito ma non come amo
mia figlia ma è sicuramente come amo mia
figlia
questo modo di caratterizzare il nostro
mondo emotivo inconscio di cui noi non
siamo neanche consapevoli perché tutte
queste persone sceglievano poi una cosa
un'altra in maniera assolutamente
inconscia Noi non sappiamo delle volte
perché scegliamo delle cose sicuramente
non scegliamo degli oggetti perché
valgono ma li scegliamo perché hanno
un'esperienza emotiva perché sono i
motivi
la profilazione emotiva passa anche
tramite i canali Social tutte le volte
che noi clicchiamo su like che mettiamo
un emoticon che scriviamo come stiamo
come ci sentiamo non facciamo altro che
dare delle informazioni sul nostro stato
emotivo su quello che ci piace o che non
ci piace
qualche tempo fa ho un famoso social
network è stato in grado di indurre una
pandemia emotiva tramite i social Che
cosa vuol dire la pandemia ormai
sappiamo tutti che cos'è Purtroppo la
pandemia da virus esiste una pandemia
emotiva quando io sono davanti e una
persona che prova una certa emozione
sono contagiato lo dicevamo Prima no il
bambino neonato che piange quando gli
altri neonati piangono io che provo
paura quando vedo un altro che prova
paura questo però di solito succedeva
fino a un po' di tempo fa nelle
interazioni personali
Ebbene i social network hanno dimostrato
che è possibile farlo anche tramite
appunto i social i canali sociali
tramite quello che io scrivo in bacheca
il Mood che trasmetto e posso contagiare
emotivamente tutti i miei contatti
Quindi vuol dire che i canali Social
sono molto potenti in alcuni casi in
alcune persone molto fragili che hanno
già dei problemi con le emozioni
l'utilizzo eccessivo di sui social può
portare un ulteriore impoverimento della
loro vita affettiva queste persone che
si chiamano gli assi chimiche quindi
fanno ancora più fatica di prima
riconoscere i propri stati emotivi
soprattutto differenziali da quelli che
sono i propri stati fisici quindi non
sanno più cosa provano e quindi non
riescono ovviamente a comportarsi
adeguatamente però cosa è successo che
proprio per queste persone in cui il
mondo emotivo è stato depauperato
soprattutto a causa appunto delle nuove
tecnologie le nuove tecnologie stesse Si
sono dimostrate uno strumento utilissimo
di psicoterapia chi fa fatica quel mondo
emotivo fa fatica nell'interazione
psicoterapica 1 a 1 perché proprio
quello il suo problema e quindi ecco
allora che tutte le App tutte le cose le
psicoterapie a distanza vengono loro in
aiuto per riprendersi il loro mondo
emotivo e funziona funziona molto bene
questa persona stanno meglio
Quindi qual è il messaggio di quello che
chiamano tutti il tè con Messenger le
nuove tecnologie i social sono
potentissimi profilano le vostre
emozioni il vostro mondo emotivo state
attenti a quello che gli raccontate
quello che gli dite Ma se da una parte
tutte queste nuove tecnologie possono
depauperare il nostro mondo emotivo
possono invece soprattutto in alcuni
casi aiutarci a prenderci cura delle
nostre emozioni
[Applauso]
[Musica]